so let's start with carmelization sobre
una una una crema catalana Fergana
sitting ambulatory Moffet Erik Estrada
Jessica Alba Kate petite tell capita so
break a tomato Judah a Poojari
black Erica the Shukra perfectly
stackable informa the copy voltar I'm
the same volition eros
purple arrow faith per cycle and thus
compile the una manera uniformly for
food area Litella
Paola la Pollock Addison Roach on Raj
ruin the Montes una temperatura LT Seim
and La Bella Supply Co so virile of
sobre la crema perfidia cocoon cravat
we don't have cast the victor are Avedon
min on Surya toha pero instantanium NK -
ah leader Kaela Lucke rescued riru-sama
mostra contouring she was in Theresa
biggity sickest evicted Academy Leeds RC
Oprah al-ma'mun
but Ashley gets shot
I guess it's time to get the stank
finger oh boy yeah a very uh good fella
pastiche okay thank you
hmm I love crema catalana little bit
thank you thank you
so caramelization is just what happens
when you heat sugar white table sugar so
sugar is just a sucrose molecule on a
sucrose is made of fructose and glucose
and so the first thing that happens when
we apply heat is that these two
molecules fall apart into glucose and
fructose and so here is sort of what
these ring structures would look at and
then these ring structures just sort of
explode into a wide array of other small
molecules and all of these molecules
have different flavors and different
smells and typically in carmelization
the flavors that we're talking about are
these sort of sherry buttery nutty
flavors and this happens at temperatures
of about 165 degrees Celsius or higher
so if we were to take these flavors and
kind of put them on a what we call a
flavor wheel which is what what wine
tasters or tasters in general would use
when they would try to sort of guide
their their pinpointing what a flavor is
and here's a flavor wheel with all of
the different flavors on everything from
earthy to nutty to fruity to to flowery
and so a caramelization kind of creates
these particular flavors that are sort
of caramely and nutty buttery and so now
keep this in mind because now we're
going to move on to my outer actions and
see what kinds of flavors those create
mired reactions in contrast to
caramelization reactions involve the
reaction between sugars and amino acids
and these typically take place at
temperatures above 120 degrees Celsius
and so what happens here is that if you
for example just take milk and heat it
there's going to be sugars in the milk
and there's going to be proteins in the
milk amino acids and the sugars are
going to react with the amino acids
and create these sort of brown or
browner compounds that have nutty
flavors and so you've probably had this
if you've ever had dulce de leche you've
had this exact same thing and there are
a lot of desserts and a lot of sauces
that sort of build on this concept of
just heating milk
and creating these flavors and so there
are many different kinds of them you
know as the stairs about 20 amino acids
and each of them the first step would be
that the glucose reacts with the amino
group on any of the amino acids and so
the amino group is a nucleophile if you
think back to chemistry and the
nucleophile is going to attack the
carbon on the glucose here and this is
then going to form a bond and this is
kind of the first step in the mired
reactions and after this there is a
whole again just an array of different
reactions that can happen the molecule
falls apart it reacts again it reacts
with each other with other glucoses with
other amino acids but this is the first
step and so you can imagine then that if
there is 20 amino acids and this is the
first step you can just imagine that
there is just a lot of different
molecules that can be created even with
with this just being the first step the
characteristic feature of my art
products is that they often contain
sulfur and nitrogen which is which comes
from the amino acids in the protein and
sulfur and protein often contributes
these kind of meaty earthy flavors that
we associate with when we cook a steak
and they're sort of this this earthy
meaty flavor and this also then
contributes to a lot of the other sort
of non distinct flavors that are very
different from the flavors that we get
in caramelization another feature that
make my ode reaction is especially
interesting from a chemical perspective
is that they're often exothermic
reactions exothermic reactions produce
heat as they happen and so as my ardh
reactions start to happen they they
produce heat and this then leads to more
reactions happening and so the speeds up
but you may have experienced this
actually if you have ever made toast so
sometimes you may have experienced that
you make toast and you wait and wait and
it's not done and it's not done and then
suddenly it's done and then it's done
and then it's over done and it has
happened very very quickly my hard
reactions of course are not only in
baking they're basically everywhere
around us so here's just a minute some
examples everything from coffee to
popcorn - champagne - a nice cured ham
are all places where mired reactions
have taken place and in some of these
cases there hasn't even
in addition of heat so in champagne for
example the the reaction is allowed to
take place over so long that the
reactions take place anyway even though
there is no input of heat but all of
these sort of earthy flavors that you
get in a champagne or in Mead they're
all they're all also due to my yard
reactions
you